is it tragic to you that
he's seen as the architect of the
nuclear age that some of his creations
led to potentially
some of his work
has has led to
potentially still the destruction of the
human species some of the most
destructive
weapons yeah
uh
but i think even more general than him i
i i give you all the virtues of
curiosity a few minutes ago there's an
interesting book called the ratchet of
curiosity you know a ratchet is
something that goes in one direction
and that that it's written by a guy
who's probably a sociologist or
philosopher or something
and he
he picks on this particular problem but
other ones and that is the the danger of
knowledge basically you know you're
curious
you learn something so it's a little bit
like curiosity killed the cat you have
to be worried about whether you can
handle new information that you get so
in this case
the new information had to do with
really understanding nuclear physics
and that information maybe we didn't
have the sophistication to
know how to keep it under control
yeah and fermi himself was
a very a political person so he wasn't
very driven by or or at least
he appears in all of his writing the
writing of his wife the interactions
that others had with him as either he
avoided it all or he was pretty
apolitical i mean he just saw the world
through kind of the lens of a scientist
but you asked if it's tragic uh
the
the bomb was tragic certainly on japan
and he had a role in that so i wouldn't
want it as my legacy for example
i mean that but broader to the human
species that
it's the ratchet of curiosity that we
um we do stuff just to see what happens
that that curiosity that uh in sort of
my area of artificial intelligence
that's been a concern
they're on a small scale on a silly
scale perhaps currently there's
constantly
unintended consequences you create a
system
and you put out there and you have
intuitions about how it will work you
have hopes how it will work but you put
it out there just to see what happens
yeah and uh in most cases because
artificial intelligence is currently not
super powerful it doesn't
create a large-scale negative effects
but that same curiosity as it progresses
might lead to something that
destroys the human species and the same
may be true for bioengineering there's
people
that
you know engineer viruses to protect us
from viruses
to see you know how do uh how close is
this to mutating so it can jump to
humans or or going you know or
engineering uh defenses against those
and it seems exciting and the
application the positive applications
are really exciting at this time but
we don't think about
how that runs away in decades to come
yeah and i think it's the same idea as
this little book the ratchet of
science the the
ratchet of curiosity i mean
whether you pursue take curiosity and
let artificial intelligence or machine
learning run away with
having its uh solutions to whatever you
want or we do it
it's i think a similar consequence
i think uh from what i've read about uh
enrico fermi he
he became a little bit cynical about the
human species towards the end of his
life
both having observed what he observed
we didn't write much
i mean he died young he died soon after
the world war
there was already you know
the
work by teller to develop the hydrogen
bomb and i think he was a little cynical
of that you know pushing it even further
and
uh rising tensions between the soviet
union and the u.s and looked like an
endless thing so but he didn't say very
much uh but a little bit as you said
that yeah there's a few clips just to
sort of uh maybe picked on a bad mood
but in in a sense that uh almost like a
sadness a melancholy sadness to
um
a hope that waned a little bit about
that uh yeah perhaps we can do
like this the science this curious
species can find the way out
well especially i think people who
worked like he did at los alamos and
spent years of their life
somehow had to convince themselves that
dropping these bombs would bring
lasting peace and it did and that it
didn't yeah
you